okay so that looks good I've done party
so now we had firmly into polynomial and
hence solve that guy okay now admittedly
have you not this is encounter crush
ladies and remembers back being the how
to do yeah okay good number thank you
guys I'm so therefore you'll be clued
into the fact that this is useful to
this precisely because of these
coefficients here right and you'll know
that you've done this right and it's
ended up a simple it will line up fairly
nicely this is the second question the
last exercise yeah as part of I pulled
it out now when you have a look at it
it's not immediately obvious right so
i'm going to write this as i'm going to
say let x equal plus theta okay our part
c is also sort of coming me and
obviously I've got to get these involved
so if I make this straight substitution
I'm going to get eight colors cubed
theta right that should make you
suspicious minus six cos theta plus one
equals zero right so I'm going to do two
things at this point I'm going to say
well if I take a factor out of to hear
i'll have the identity that I was after
so I just had to say that is actually 2
cos 3 theta plus 1 do that from party
and what I'm actually trying to do is
solve this thing right so having reduced
this cubic right this polynomial into
just a standard trig function that's the
barbarians super right it turns powers
in terms of powers into just linear
things which I'm very easy to deal with
my comparison right so this I just need
to rearrange a teeny bit
and I get that is that ok now just pause
it's been a little while since we dealt
with these in detail so I want you to
remember like all we have to do is solve
but I find students are still getting a
bit confused the game their wires
crossed just when they do this simple
step the duel is high flow I'm a fancy
instead of just in it and then they get
tripped up on solving a trig equation ok
and also remembering aware of radians I
just thought I'd spend a bit of time I
Center provides its to thank the way I
do my diagram when I'm solving this is I
draw the actual plate I don't just draw
a triangle especially when there are
negatives involved right sign direction
indicates quadrants are going to be
important so minus one over to cause you
can see I'm going to be over here does
that make sense so I say adjacent
hypotenuse that's what caused views so
here is the whatever to Jay said my
partner's something like that right
there's my 1 and x 2 I don't really like
drawing a triangle like just out in the
middle there and saying theta minus 1
and 2 that's weird it's a lame it should
be doing that the negative indicates
direction doesn't indicate manager right
so that's why I put it I bother to draw
myself read minds in that way I can see
it quadrants it's also going to be
helpful for other reasons it of
synthetic so where is the angle that I'm
interested in are keeping my sis is root
3 what kind of triangle is this one of
the angles ratings
this is a 32 this is play on six up here
you can even see it if you drawn it even
reasonably well and that makes this play
on three yes now where is freedom where
is 3 theta in this diagram look at it
carefully you always measure from the
positive x-axis it goes all the way
around like so we go do that so that
angle there which I can see this is PI
so I want the supplement with pylon 3
this angle is 2.3 are you happy with
that so I'm now solving for three thin
up my first solution is too high on
three but clearly I have more solutions
right which quadrant will my next
solution of you third quadrant you get
the gun just two ways you can anything
okay I can think my all stations to
central thing or you could just be a
little more abstractly sophisticated
about it and remember the cosine on the
unit circle like which coordinate is
cause on the unit circle it's the
x-coordinate right the x coordinate is
negative so of course you're going to be
a left hand side this is where all the
negatives are so that's why I'm in this
quarter so making the same kind of
diagram you can see I'm getting this guy
right by symmetry you can see this
angling here is PI on three and where is
three feet up now
yeah again measuring from the positive
x-axis and you're going all the way
around you see that and you can see okay
I go pie and then I go an article I go
another pile 3 which gives you four yeah
okay that's why now yes that's right so
I'm going to talk about principle I get
it in a minute okay I actually think
since you gotta be careful principal
arguments are nice and therefore tying
things in a borrowed but I think it's
dangerous to invoke them where it's not
necessary where the question is not
sending me about we will get to why do
the interest rate the arguments in a
minute but I want to deal with that when
I when I'm supposed to do not what I'm
just trying to solve this thing yeah i'm
just being smart in this question you
see as the answers
now that is a great question it's
reasonable interest rate for you why but
an important thing like I told you guys
about winter winter interest in exactly
one of the critical things that we're
looking for like why are we so antsy
about students doing working like we
want to see that you understand this not
that you can just manipulate that right
like that's the skill as being assessed
so if you can sort of like students do
this all the time like if you're a
student like just put yourself in to try
and imagine imagine would be from arab i
heard by fri you'll never been in the
situation but you made a question like
this and you know nothing about like
zero you're going to look at this and
you say well my early options are to
take what's already there and try and
twist it around and do some reversing
and then and then use my calculator heck
of a lot and it hopefully get to
something like that or some solution to
it and that's no more each other's heads
under cestus